what's up everybody welcome to GameSpot
laughs we're back another action-packed
day
I'm Persia I'm here with Ritchie today
and we're checking out some zombies call
of duty black ops 4 just dropped new
updates operation apocalypse Z's so
there's ton of new stuff new maps and
stuff for black out multiplayer action
and then also a brand new zombies mode
which is called Alpha Omega I believe
and um yeah so we're gonna check that
out we were talking a little bit before
about all the zombie modes we've played
but this one's pretty cool because it's
based in new town it is and has some
familiar faces they're bringing back the
old aether timeline so we're gonna see
some familiar faces here some familiar
voices and playing some familiar
territory for sure yes it's gonna be
pretty exciting and you know I was
excited to play in general but I didn't
realize how many other zombie modes I
have played before until we were sitting
down and talking about it I just don't
remember which version of like Call of
Duty they were from I just remember
flying them a lot cuz that's how many
there have been should I think like once
you go back and start recapping it like
me it's a lot of different zombie modes
yeah it was just a big bunch like I
don't even I can't pinpoint him I've
been playing him for years and I can I
can't pick out which ones come from
which game all the time so maybe we'll
do a little fun pop quiz with the chat
will describe with version to you and
see if you guys can let us know which
ones from for sure all the descriptions
are bad we're just like remember that
one yeah with the people exactly it's
gonna be fun anyway let's get this
started also a beautiful title screen
here we're liking this for sure it's
like yeah
let's go but yes let's do this only
waiting for a modernwarfare yes that is
true
modern warfare I believe when you
download this update they talk about it
too and there's like a little trailer
for modern warfare like it's back yeah
oh should we go with the public match or
just me solo it'll be one of us playing
at a time but yeah we're gonna take
turns but you know what I'd say go into
a public match because I feel like
zombies is always more fun with a group
true people it is it does get like a
little harder but it's still fun and you
know having more people to help you like
revive instantly or you're playing on
your own makes it easier but like it's
definitely fun or with more people and
you can survive for much longer so I was
playing this is zombie mode a little bit
and there's just so many new things like
there's potions and powerup well I mean
power-ups all we've been always been a
thing but there's like potions where if
you get hit by a zombie
you can light them on fire and it
sustains for three attacks and like
different things like that which i think
is pretty cool
yeah I forget to use them sometimes and
I'm in like the heat of like the Horde
me too
feel free to remind us if I don't use
them because I'd like to consider myself
like an old school just bare-bones
you just had shoes on it was just like
the box and like the soda machines like
that's about it I do remember the candy
a little bit and whatever the gumballs
it's new school for me yeah yeah so
that's great yeah this loadings doing
this cool because I think it's
screenshots from a little light from
other parts of Call of Duty all of me
that's so it's pretty cool oh wow it's
over I'm doing great thank you Willis he
says how are you guys doing hey what's
up doing good
how are you doing man thanks for joining
us
happy Thursday all around we're almost
at the end of the week I know right it's
it's round one oh yeah don't forget I
changed your controls you might need to
switch those back to normal
I've been playing this way get the most
points early aren't you stabbed I know
why I was shooting anyone look at round
2 I think it's time I know right already
around look at the success
we're great one guy didn't even move yet
I know crazy oh oh legend possible we're
glad you followed us too ok so it's fun
to know that like this map is gonna be a
little more expanded because it's played
for years it's its new town exactly like
you haven't quite run into the part of
new town that we're all used to just yet
but it's like one stage away it's so
like as we start unlocking barriers how
many times have you camped in that house
I need money come on I know right
that's right level three already man
your teammate already has 1800 bucks man
[Laughter]
actually I'm okay but this pistols gonna
get weaker and weaker you all know how
it goes ducks
that's a potion tune and I mean all it
does is it just like gives them ducky
floaties yeah I think one of the people
is not here they might be partied up
with somebody so he's trying to protect
them until he gets back but this area is
gonna go him if you guys don't unlock
another area and all the song music
where's my money
okay 1490 yeah this looks like this
might be away and that one shut down
on the end maybe this way delicious oh
yeah cuz there's some weapons to buy
over here got a shoddy though hello love
the sound effects a plus turn the game
volume down encourages volume down and
Ritchie's volume up oh ok so I'll turn
mine down game volume downs
thank you thank you yes thank you
Ritchie's Micah's already all the way up
oh maybe I'll just speak up I'll just
sorry about that
there we go yeah there you everybody
like straight on ok it's still just us
two we're trying to figure out like what
these guys are up to
doesn't look like much hopefully yeah
just the luck of the draw got some some
dudes got the wolfy's yeah I mean
luckily early on they died of like one
hit I was playing earlier we were like
level like 15 there were pretty beefy
and it was terrifying
you know this one doesn't count because
you had two teammates that are in really
playing to don't be a dead guy help out
that's the the lesson here Oh Matthew
thank you thanks Matthew says this games
awesome I mean you guys are hilarious oh
and there's a fire sale going on and I
can't even be a part of it I know right
somebody help me please
man this guy has oh yeah that's another
thing you can you can press like l1 and
r1 after you build up your special gauge
and your class gets a you know super
ability I'm so glad wait for a while you
like on your class you get like this
really awesome flamethrower oh my
goodness the dog is
[Laughter]
and yeah the one that that guy had is
really cool he can like ground pound and
it destroys everybody the one you have
the flamethrower and it's like really
Opie also holy interesting okay there
are a lot of options over here to the
right of my screen there I'm having your
potions can I help myself up those are
for when you're already alive alright
you know what
redo redo yet okay the whole games are
dead we're all dead anyway
nope let's uh let's start that again
shall we
yeah yeah yeah you wait for that and
there we go the FS coming in that's
rolling but yeah we were talking about
past a zombie modes we've played oh you
know what here let's let this boom I'm
sure there's a list so I'm gonna
describe the ones and then chat has to
try to get it right Raymond thank you
yep rip blame me it's fine
this game is looking sweet says Willis
so far I have to agree it looks very
cool I just wish those guys were a
little more helpful and I was a little
bitter but yeah exactly it was luck at
the draw unfortunately here we go
oh man I'm looking at this list of all
the zombie modes now and even with this
list I really can't tell which ones I
play man yeah yeah exactly I need a
visual aid Nick was the best that card
and any other game miss him crime we
miss him - he was my go-to guy alright I
was his go-to guy we team up and do
these Cod things shout out to Nick
wherever you are Missy bud okay well win
this one for him in his honor yes level
1 million damn by the way if you want to
give it a shot you you know what you're
doing Oh
okay I'll do what anything was better
than those last teammates it exactly
oh yeah I'll do one hopes the chat is
live yeah let's go chat rage quit
zombies yeah I kind of little less
rageful but we had to start off on the
right foot and that was not it okay I
think these guys are not reading up so
we're gonna leave this lobby and we're
gonna find a new one okay man may I see
these are the classes exterminator
this I think this one which one is it it
might be that one that's the super cheap
one oh I'm not unlocked yet it's
exterminator exterminator sounds good
sounds powerful
it's so nice to see all these familiar
faces they're all younger there's so
many timelines zombie universe these are
the the oldest dudes it really is like a
zombie universe yeah it's a whole like
own thing especially with characters
returning definitely these guys are
familiar faces for sure
alright you guys tell me if you know
which zombie mode were talking about I'm
gonna describe it and if you guys name
one and we find it on this list and I'm
just gonna assume it right oh I've read
it up oh you did think we're waiting for
zombie boy here oh this is not ready
it's come on the most ready we all four
have to be ready okay there we go all
right so I remember playing a zombie
mode where there was like a movie set
and there was a big bow I think there
was also some ice like a cold and I know
we're doing something give you guys some
time yeah to think on that some
celebrities perhaps perhaps
wink wink hint hint man so many of them
like this list oh my gosh yes oh no
that's not it
that's this key Willis Brown asks are
you going live tomorrow tomorrow yes
this community Friday so Ben and John
Luke should be here to do that goodness
winner the Aiden player wait no oh wait
I think that is all right to me it
sounds right also confirmed we're so bad
at our own game that we created there we
go more people are saying call the dead
oh yeah
yes very good yeah that sounds like oh
yeah there it is boom found it oh here
we go all right let's do this he didn't
change this no I didn't touch no no you
still got the button puncher mode noise
tactical but in apex called button
penetrator oh we have the color
technically that's right okay very nice
squishy the sound work a 1 I've always
found it fascinating people who work on
sound effects because the things that
they ask to use to actually make those
sound effects are sometimes the most
weird and unconventional things oh come
on is that zombie boy a [ __ ] I remember
doing that in film school like I kind of
wanted to be the guy who made the sound
effects when growing up and when I learn
how to do it you do use just about
anything so it was great there was a
whole room just full of that there we go
yes it was a call the dead with George
Romero yeah Trejo great transit we're
calling that one out that one's fun
that's the bus one yeah thing about that
too that one is really there you need
your friends or it's like gonna go
nowhere fast and there's like some
puzzles in it too which I personally
enjoy because I get to build the fan to
blow down the wall like oh yeah silly
stuff yeah there should be a game of
survival as you know originally and then
they added puzzles and stories and it's
crazy and ducks ducks ducks everywhere
Oh God oh god it miss all three of those
level three yeah they're gonna start to
get harder maybe that shotgun or here we
go Tommy gun yeah oh no I thought it was
is it no it's a little handgun oh no oh
I was about to say then I was picked it
up that it disappeared
whoa my best wave on Ascension crazy I
don't even think I got that far with
four PPI no geez possible really is a
legend I remember going to the cod
forums and be like can I please get
someone to play I know love ten years
old has a mic and then I got exactly
what I wanted and we got to we got so
far in Ascension it was they were too
good so it was just kidding it was crazy
up until like 50 or 60 levels for it to
get really good and I got down and they
helped me out so I think so when you're
down and then you oh there's a dog yeah
when you're down you're getting revived
noise noise okay you know I'm gonna use
this potion which look like Crown Royal
supreme I know it was the same like
bottle oh yeah
mmm you the go well it's brown you're
too kind man thank you thank you all for
joining us today I know you guys tune in
for some zombies cuz I mean zombies is
just really fun
I like modes that you know you so play
with friends not exactly multiplayer but
it's still fun like horde mode and Gears
I love word mode oh man yeah almost more
than actually just playing gears by
itself yep that's that's a you're not
alone in that one for sure
they should put some old-school
okay who remembers the zombie mode where
there was the crazy mad scientist that
would come out every few rounds and he
was he was terrifying he was crazy
you're always like no not again oh that
little gun is a handful that's great oh
yeah has a massive clip which is awesome
yeah that's why I thought it was a tommy
gun there you got like a drum magazine
on that thing
great oh yeah Matthew says this is call
of duty zombies and game lol because
everyone comes back the blip now we're
in the middle of new town okay it looks
so good woah oh I had my potion though
oh it's text me for three hits and it's
on fire that's great teleport pad which
is not available five look at the chat
yep
very good y'all yeah I told you they're
gonna know them all there you know
that's some dedicated fans in here Oh
pull the dogies oh not go somewhere can
anyone in the chat tell us one of the
dogies first appeared I forget I think I
remember the map I don't know if I
remember the name there are alive oh we
got a new gun I didn't notice very good
look at this you're doing better than I
am already
we've made it to level six but where's
the zombies out my teammates are just
killing it legal pays good are they whoa
whoa he couldn't decide what he wanted
to be he jumped at that boy not still a
good boy just he doesn't know I know I
like even when dogs are evil and games
I'm still like
using games like geez this behavior is
taught all dogs are good at heart
don't turn them evil oh you know what
they buff about max ammo it's that is
that um you know before when you grabbed
a max ammo and you'd like how to you
didn't have a full clip first yeah now
it just gives you maximum all the way
that's great yeah big win oh my gosh oh
the bunker we're in the underground
bunker of Newtown now by the way guys
you guys remember in the regular map
there is something here and I don't
remember if it looks exactly like this
bunker but I do remember there being
something yeah it might have been here
the whole time we just didn't even know
he no I think that is the map where the
dog showed up the first time I forget
that no I remember the theater when that
one is really cool crime says they are
not sea dogs so it's okay hot cake Oh
insta kill oh man you guys are all
reminiscing about the older maps this is
good that's good right there with you
those old maps are like just so
nostalgic for me it's a hard to thing
how old they are now but I played them
all since I myself played the early ones
in the world that were starting from
there well from the beginning yeah like
I remember one the first one its first
on whatever it was like the one it was
like I don't know wasn't like a mansion
or something and he started in like the
lobby
imagine hmm-hmm he's like a man she's
starting like a lobby and there's like
stairs on the left and the right went up
see when you mentioned a lobby I'm
thinking of the theater one again
because I'm starting to lobby there also
so I can't I can't
it's like there have been so many in
like some of them have different parts I
was like oh yeah remember the moon the
moon I go to the moon
I remember that one bite never actually
okay that one oh my god but I like love
the idea of that space stuff it was zero
gravity zombies quanta that's been 10
years already
oh my god throwing hands very good oh my
god that guy's helping us out - oh no
you know I vaguely remember in other
jambe modes you could kind of jump over
them like glitch around them it's
probably something they fix people
stop trying to be kwan says the moon was
awesome with the monkeys yeah oh my god
even though I might do more damage
you're doing great you're already at
level 9 and we have a fully
participating team I know it's beautiful
crime - Oh cam he's this potion which
they get headshots and increases the
chances of an insta-kill love that
that's cool two minutes
what are those that last option you have
on the right where the guy's like
holding something on the left one or
their top one the top one is the one
that gives me in skill if I get a
headshot that's the one a chance to be
yeah okay okay okay oh so I get a chance
to insta kill them I love this really
it's the one I play with the most
probably when I was playing a multi
basically in a cave a little more yeah
yeah I feel like the recoil actually is
much better on this than the inkay yeah
that's what I meant like it's a reduced
recoil that's good very good I don't
know what these do and that ones are
expensive it's a 5k what do you have
right now Morgan I'm like China's day
with my teammates but it's always like
nerve-racking seeing them super far away
I'm like oh hey Raymond is Chen for us
in the chat don't die don't die he also
agrees that the moon the moon map was
awesome it was a fun map that was a
weird time personally because a lot of
people that I used to play Cod with like
weren't playing so much anymore
so I played that one with a lot of
randoms hmm but still I wanted to play
cuz it was so good I got this one guy
here willing to stick around yeah all
right everyone okay and I have my
flamethrower at the ready waiting for ya
my special ability sick everyone in chat
list off some of your favorite Cod maps
yeah it might help us remember which
ones leave plates yeah that's I think
what was the one where it was like it
was kind of like an outside map but you
it was pretty big and you had to run
around and then I remember there being
like this huge one a huge like guy that
would come around every few might but it
was also kind of puzzle intensive to it
like you had to run over to this side
and do this one thing and then I ran
over to the other okay there was a
boyfriend oh he's down oh yeah yes I
have to remember how to get out of here
there was that the original one in
Alcatraz kind of had a similar set up I
mean you remember that prison one I
think that my table of the Dead yeah I
think that one was it cuz I do remember
there being
sell some stuff hmm that one was good
that was fun and they they
reincorporated it back into the timeline
using these characters that was fine
but it's so crazy the end of that it's
just like there are so many timelines
and it's a million ways it's very
thoughtful and confusing stories
mama the dead oh that's your cue that
means dogies yeah that's cool the same
sound effect it's still and still flicks
all this fear in my head well there was
- oh no no oh no I shouldn't use the
flamethrower but like part of me was
being like like with the big old the big
old weapons it's okay my home someone
with a giant stomping crime I think is
this from ghosts are advanced without
forget there was one where there was
some big-ass robots and you lost me
there but I want you to I'm glad you if
you're I'm glad you liked that map I
remember playing it maybe like once or
twice I wasn't into it oh my god the
graphic says Kevin they're very nice new
town has never looked so good kind of
want to go to the box I have so much
money go for it yeah I mean I think in
this one if you use it once it goes away
Quan fetch me their souls yes that was
the doggy round for sure I could hug in
the box
[Music]
okay let's do it
I don't want to be next to the guy with
the stinger yeah I know oh come on
zombies did anyone in the chat play The
Chronicle's missions they were just like
the old school missions but they put him
on the ps4 that was fun that was a fun
way to like play the old maps I don't
even think I have my 360 oh dang darn it
I wasted my flamethrower and that guy
stole the Raygun nah he paid for it that
was rightfully his okay fine box he's
got a riot shield and everything Wow
yeah I'm thinking oh
Brendon asks how much of the story do
you guys know like I'm definitely the
type of FPS player where I will go
straight to multiplayer before I go yeah
the story that's fair I just all
straight up in mid-thigh right there but
I from the story modes I have played
it's pretty cool I just think when it
comes to leg military shooters you know
it's always like hey let's go defeat
this gang you know somewhere it's like
you know it's always it feels pretty the
same yeah it's a for the cod that was
probably what was so fun about the
zombies storyline because like while the
the main stories and black ops and world
at war was very gritty and realistic and
futuristic the zombies was always like
this fantastical side so I like with
crazy science fiction potions very
creative it was like a very fun way to
for the creator to like stretch her legs
and like try something just fun and at
first it started off very quiet like the
very first zombie map was kind of just
like this there was it wasn't like what
I'm looking at right here it was just
very straightforward no perks no
power-ups no voices I don't even think
but it turned into this crazy story and
the story is all over the place but I
remember I would say I know just about
like half of it when like I recognize
these characters but as far as what's
actually going on is a little more
cloudy I kind of get the base but I
don't want to misspeak about the
storyline either all I know is Persia is
killing it yeah
level 13 right now with this squad
meanwhile what did I get to level 3 oh
yeah but those maps have evolved over
the years they were used to speak like
horde mode and then attorney the stories
and puzzles and multiple storylines oh
man what about the Zeus cannon I wish
they would bring that gun back the Zeus
cannon I do remember holy crap that
thing just pushed everyone out of the
way like it was a gust of wind and if
that hasn't returned since yeah I've
always liked the stuff like the special
stuff you can get out of the secret the
mystery box like it was always wonky
stuff like you know a little monkey ball
and I'll distract people really do you
remember the pack-a-punch machine yeah
that's the thing I think make your guns
like super awesome
yeah just no that's not it was like
level 13 huh
look over there
[Music]
it's okay our teammates got me that
seriously looked like the pack-a-punch
machine and I blew it
Oh No okay what a friend mine mister you
[Music]
don't want that rampage yeah it's like a
shotgun
you can press B and/or a circle oh my
gosh too many constantly gifted yeah
gift it pretty much crime says you can
still do it Persia yeah oh no I I
switched off the wrong gun that looked a
lot cooler than across super Oh P is it
okay oh man but it's it became fun to
like start to figure out what the Easter
eggs were and Easter Egg started to turn
into like the plots and the puzzles of
all these zombie maps so like when you
play a new zombies map you're looking
for like what's what can i press to like
activate besides the power you know like
great what how can I continue this
storyline because it's not just about
killing zombies so much anymore it's
crazy the story at least one lone zombie
somewhere like those are the strats back
in the days like okay shoot the legs off
of this on me so he's just crawling
around so we can go farm the windows and
get some gold yep
just kind of relax for a little bit make
some crawlers yeah that was the strap
back then I'm not sure do they still
like encourage making crawlers cuz they
east for a while they the developers
knew that people were doing that and
they they killed off crawlers like they
would crawl around for a little and then
they would just die
that guy no behind him oh you guys got
each other's backs here yeah this
teamwork Wow you guys are like oh my god
the reload time when this kind of
something I'm gonna use this potion
that's more crown okay cool that one's
fun that music means it's about to get
real yeah like I'm going now
this gun is like great cuz I was a big
cliff but it's like so slugs I
appreciate all okay don't like real sad
that I stuck with this crossbow yeah it
just looks so cool it's hard to turn
down
wait does that shoot two crossbows okay
my grenade did some stuff oh there's two
of us down someone got needs to kill
wait did they know oh nice nice nice
okay this guy's goat right here so I
have my special ability to Wow all right
you know what
everybody burn taking some revenge here
I know I'm like we love Calvin cloy cod4
was definitely one of my favorite cuts
ever it was my first one ooh what is
going oh my god
oh man alright so my choice of weapons
here
tonio dome oh there's three of us down
this might be the end where is the last
guy standing
oh he's running away okay yeah run for
your life bro
try and supers
it's real sad goodness it's it's real
it's real tough you try to clean up just
gonna try to shoot him with my good
intentions the great thing is you get
revived with full life that isn't it oh
no he was very good match
we're trash the mystery box did me wrong
can I get another F in the chat I don't
know if I can
I did a lot of running around and like
not enough zombie killing you you get a
lot of zombie killing get all the wonder
weapons they're better anyway that's the
goal I know right we love wonder weapons
just needed a few of those box purchases
to work out in my favor
yeah rib you don't know where the pack
of punch is no not yet looking for that
thing so many apps thank you it's
regenerating us I appreciate that
smart ain't paying some respects here in
the chat see you later unknown God
thanks for tuning in happy Thursday if
we don't see it tomorrow have a good
weekend yeah thank you
all-time best for firing those now nice
and you were playing yesterday were you
ready are they sticking around I mean
they didn't see too bad they should
stick around one day left it was Tony
all right I read it up didn't I no
that's they want you to confirm you're
ready now we have clips 25 let's go the
maker everyone saying oh it's crime
saying it's in the bunker I think yo
guys
Oh pack-a-punch I mean I think so yeah
yeah Chris so large though that doesn't
help me crime
just kidding we'll find it we need it if
we need to get further here ah one guy
left man not this list of all the zombie
modes it's a wave I thought I played a
lot of belonging loves but neligan's
does listen like I'm not playing enough
oh my gosh you guys should play apex 1
we love that game yeah we do indeed love
that game the whole office loves like
we've played it a few times on the
stream like season 2 just drop so we
played although we got body that day all
right I'm not even gonna lie we got body
that day was probably not our best
showing but the time before that we got
two wins on stream I mean so that's just
how it goes
yeah they're seasoned vets here like I'm
not allowed to do that and play apex cuz
I stink so I'm really glad max and Eric
and perjury can hold it down yeah I felt
like looking max play together like we
do really well they carry me a lot but
I'm like flying somebody's like oh
thanks for killing it wrong guys here's
a bot here boy take the care package you
guys need the gold shield yeah exactly
contribution yeah and you can heal
faster that's good
this is I can't get over this is so cool
it's like a just a big oh what's the
word we have one of them at work like a
big picture where that's made up of a
bunch of oh yeah it's like artsy things
um play a different map do they have
more maps right now I know that this one
just came out so they probably do have
some other versions but
we're just you know given this one a
couple of runs since it's showing some
love brand-new yeah there are there are
new features within multiplayer maps but
zombies for I mean you're pretty low
level so multiplayer is gonna be super
rough yeah but you know I'm having fun
with the zombie mode me too we're
finally getting are getting the hang of
it a little bit here don't shoot you got
these guys are rookies I was shooting do
you remember that there you go get in
there let's get some money alright I I'm
going to let you guys know the new stuff
with operation apocalypse see that's not
just the slimy stuff because they
dropped a ton of other stuff so now you
have to get power-ups because that
potion makes them last longer
crab trying to inspect my weapon so
let's see in multiplayer of this new
patch there's a new specialist called
Reaper there's a new game mode called
sticks and stones and then the new maps
are and forgive me I'm gonna butcher
these names
Durer Shatan remnant and havana and then
a new alternate map jungle flooded plus
more and then in black out there's new
map updates the haunting fog an
apocalyptic transformation to the main
map alcatraz nightfall the prison island
under the cover of darkness in new
gamemodes so quads fog a limited-time
quads playlist we're cloudy skies
hangover an ominous fog spooky alcatraz
portals horde an Alcatraz game-mode with
more zombies enemy types that spawn
throughout the map ooh nice maybe we'll
play it out a little bit too this game
is huge there's so much content in this
game
this is just like one like update yeah
like there's lunch in blackout there's
also new weapons and equipment and then
there's also three new playable
characters in shadows rustman and Danny
Trejo
very cool Danny Trejo returning he was
in that uh he was in Call of the Dead
and em shadows from Avenged Sevenfold
he's uh you can unlock like an easter
egg that would play in avenged sevenfold
song and now you can play as the lead
singer from a very cool I like all of
the celebrity video game crossovers
we've been having this like their heart
is here it's pretty great and then
zombies mode obviously the new
experience which we've been playing now
alpha-omega
new elixirs head trauma and phoenix up
new perk blood wolf bite plus more and
then there's there's even more on the
black market
40 new controverts contraband stream
tears zombies themed specialist outfits
at school new master crafts and mk2
weapons earnable ultra weapon bribe
there was also something else
i think they added that I saw that was
like a non dupe like creep pretty much
okay yeah that's good so let's see a few
more details here about the new
specialist for multiplayer Reaper he's a
heavily-armed robotic specialist oh no
wow another bastion every game want
Sebastian we have fashion we have finder
and now Reaper also looks like
Pathfinder there's like stages to this
like Bastion is like the PG version and
then Pathfinder you know he's like no I
would say bastions G rating huh amen
Pathfinder's like PG because you know
he's a little bit more advanced but he's
also still pretty friendly sure and in
our Reaper he's just like rated R yep
so intense in this so yeah he's a
heavily armed robotic specialist that
utilizes explosive firepower to gain the
upper-hand reaper a special issue
weaponry is the scythe a high damaged
machine gun with explosive rounds in a
fast fire rate that also inflicts a
suppression status effect to nearby
enemies Reaper a special issue equipment
the radar shroud is a deployable jamming
device that conceals an area on an enemy
mini-map noise this equipment allows
Reaper and his teammates to operate
undetected within the shrouds radius
Reaper is available at Tier one of the
operation and will be playable in
multiplayer once unlocked so interesting
previously there was a bunch of content
yeah if you guys want to get back into
cod or if you're still playing you'll
have a lot to work with here yeah
that sounds pretty cool so it's like he
has all this crazy firepower machine gun
explosive rounds but then he also has a
way to like make themself e on the
mini-map which is great because you know
that's a huge thing in cod yeah yeah
sure go ahead and fire but now I know
where you are
yep you blew it so that's actually
really interesting to me and sounds like
something a little big game changing for
the meta in cod in general because it
was like you ride to run around with a
silenced weapon that didn't do as much
damage so you got to get good or have
Reaper on your team so he could just
cover up on the map and you can go him
one says gotta go guys guys are awesome
you're awesome too
thanks for watching yeah thanks for
watching they should put rappers back
yeah remember they should be fun
someone's this plays little yachty okay
here we go I can finally read this thing
heck yeah
yeah anything's better than lapis yeah I
was gonna say it looks like the Galil
alright what else what else oh yeah so
sticks and stones returns and they they
consider this a party game so players
are only given a crossbow a ballistic
knife and a combat axe so yeah I
remember sticks and stones before yeah I
can't hang there we go oh geez
it's such a rookie using my gun I'm
getting out numbered here there we go
no sometimes like having an automatic
weapon insta kill I'm just like I think
that's how you should and I'm playing
very conservatively but yeah I have a
gun let's use it actually I have a new
right brought a gun to a new exciting
cool one of the weapons in sticks and
stones it's called the backhander and
it's a disembodied zombie arm that
functions as a one hit kill melee weapon
I'm super fun let's go and if you guys
want to see the pictures for some of
these new maps and some of the map
changes for some of the blackout maps
then just go on over to Treyarch comm
they got some pretty cool scripts like
screenshots and pictures oh boy potatoes
so that you guys can see here about what
else they've dropped in operations of
the hakka Lindsay whoa fire sale at a
time like this
right we have I saw this oh now they're
all going for the box all right fine me
next me next
come on me next
I'll make it or leave it bro you don't
have time for this
I know right I don't want the ramp no
one wants the right now I got a big
birthday but yeah there's like a ton of
other stuff like details about black
market and everything else but it's just
so much that you guys should probably
just go to them yeah it's out now or
just yeah we talked about all of the
really good stuff there ooh I haven't
been to this part yet they're getting a
little tougher here why am i reloading
[Laughter]
hello
I'm not gonna lie whenever I play and
there's all these mannequins everywhere
I start getting all paranoid and I'm
just like shooting a mannequin - I might
as well they're not inviting you're not
helping you can catch it too well but
[ __ ] okay we should all stick together
you would think that would be the
strategy but I feel like whenever you go
and play with like people in matchmaking
they never want to stick with you like
come on man
yeah it depends on who you get it always
shifts around I try to stick with the
group because just we have a better
chance or we can kill each other you
know it's all good things but I see why
you want to run off on your own it's
hard because you want to go exploring -
and open and unlock things but you gotta
stick close now let's see if I can find
that pack-a-punch machine
we gotta crank said it was in the bunker
[Music]
Oh No
another one opened up oh wow no run
faster I think and for longer mix of
those oh look at that look at me go
don't have enough for it no I don't want
clothes I think I want to get rid of my
shotgun here soon
oh yeah okay you drop that fatty yeah
right yeah oh you also have your flame
there over whoa I don't want an r1
together I'm gonna do it the Persian
that they can use my gun is one bullet
now I just spin in circles holding down
the trigger
never take me where my friends oh yeah
stabbing some pudding yeah oh the combos
insta-kill it's a nuke okay that works
that works you reload everything I mean
I'm doing good on em oh okay
ooh they're down there I got to figure
out where they are stick it together
friends here we go this is press right
on your d-pad right now yeah yeah zombie
Roy out real quick that's right so we
can get like some protection against the
the hits Oh
Milou yes he he's on fire now okay cool
okay all my friends are here hmm
these aren't open yet are these aren't
activated we need to turn on the power I
believe or whatever is some sort of
generator I'm sure you rebuild
I can't rebuild this wall just not how
it goes anymore I guess Oh something
wrong with the machines
I have enough to open this let's keep
going yeah I've gotta go find this pack
a punch
yeah I'm trying to pack some punches
hmm all of us here dying wish
I'm familiar with this one I am NOT but
it's five grands so it must be important
yeah and I'm broke
story of my life yeah oh and in cod yeah
um let's see fish win purchase will
prevent the player from falling into
last name no I like that though I would
have saved up and bought at last game if
I would have known oh we got we got
power-ups would you turn them ablaze oh
I think you're out now oh I can't take
any more hits running with this big gun
yeah things like 50 pounds I skipped leg
day oh no I thought that was a good
thing yeah I naturally wanted to reload
but I don't need you I like how the
voice actor he gets like more and more
demonic every yeah used to be like max
now he's actually he's a final boss at
the end probably oh did you see that
mukha asks called you your battlefield
what do you think ooh
well I feel like they're they're the
same but they offer different fighting
styles I guess you could say like cod is
all about head glitching and fault can't
run in there
oh no they're following the other guys
Wow
does he like was that a perk Oh fire
sale I can't stop to buy good I need to
get good no where's that machine that
lets me reload faster nope no corners oh
when you get back up use your
flamethrower l1 and r1 at the same time
that's what I tried earlier okay I'll
try it again l1 r1 maybe holds it down I
just know you have to press them both ah
you guys were talking about something
and I was gonna ask a chat a question
but we were like so into this oh yeah
so yeah they feel like they offer
different you know they offer different
things in the same field looks like Call
of Duty head glitch you know hide behind
walls find the best vantage point in
battlefield if I'm thinking correctly
like you could destroy the wall I was
like oh you know why you're gonna camp
over there boom nothing camp behind it
just really cold
so I think it's cool I am personally
have played way more hot than I played
battlefield me too it's also a matter of
like you know we were talking about this
earlier to like Call of Duty is like a
legacy game like all the skill you've
had you know playing Cod's will transfer
over immediately to any other new Cod
right it's not like oh hey I'm playing
Cod and hey a new Halo came out let me
see if I can transfer what I know it's
like yeah you might like aim and shoot
but it's like totally different concepts
which is like similar to Tekken if
anyone's play Tekken like older Tekken
games like all those characters are the
same in the newer type conversions when
it comes to their moves and things at
work there might be a few different
changes but it's mostly the same and
that knowledge from the older games can
carry over so that's how I feel about
Cod and like playing it so whenever I
feel like I just want to pop in a game
and feel good about myself something
familiar
like Call of Duty's that you same if you
played them throughout the years you you
at least feel comfortable like you know
you're doing especially like when black
out showed up play and talk I'm
surrounded I feel like we need to get
rid of this gun you're using yeah it's I
got to either speed it up or get rid of
it and flamethrower I don't forget the
flames all right but wait until you got
like a bunch of people on you yeah Wow
mo oh great recording yes you guys all
have to turn on the ventilation so when
you're running through these hallways
you're not getting like high off of
these fumes no works cuz yeah I'm seeing
like cloudy areas and I can't like no
they're running away from me oh no one
of our friends is down way so far away
okay okay
you join our friends and let's go having
some barbecued zombie no he was trying
to revive them bless you
noise the meter drains over time so
you're almost out and maybe like one or
two seconds but you got this just enough
time to roast them yeah that was very
helpful I'll help you here buddy
welcome to the roast of the call of duty
zombies wow this area is like again no
time for this I don't know why I picked
it up or where the box is at the moment
I think it's still above us ooh
level 4 it seen we're gonna break our
extreme record right here can any of
these open I want to go through we're
way to split up this stinks Mooka says
so those who own ps2 back in the day do
you remember game called SOCOM 3 u.s.
Navy SEALs I never remember SOCOM that
was when I got as far as 300 games you
could like
play online on the ps2 and I didn't have
a modem so I didn't get into so I'm good
at cornering myself oh my gosh it's a
very like COD thing to try to like run
to something and hop over it but in
there just like portals or the zombies
come through words to me got you there
we go yes I've got three or Natas that's
right okay I'll cover you hey Vincent
what's up Vincent well hope you like cod
and cod zombies I love me some zombies
whoo man y'all are rich though y'all
need to go buy go find the box you're a
level 14 I think the oh cool I'm just
like actually starting to pay attention
to what's inside this bunker it looks
like oh yeah your teammate had the same
idea he's like where the box at I didn't
even realize it was protecting you now
just go the box okay oh I see the light
okay I think hi already Greg says pack a
punch also can drop from the sky every
five rounds inches Oh interesting thank
you crime crime always has the tech
crime yeah good old chat here we go
there are Wikipedia I saw the Raygun
like pop out okay I'm rich scary
[Music]
that just means a box home is that the
bear yeah they replaced the baby no I
missed the bear what was that oh no of
course
when I needed the gun the most Maximo
you're really close to getting your um
your flamethrower back you just got a
he'll be late for that
oh okay cool yeah that little green
meter right over oh he does have monkey
bombs
where'd the box go there's no lights
there under-appreciated maybe it's in
the bunker does the light shine through
that's a good question I was wondering
that too or does the mannequin mean your
guys are done the box is gone forever
they'll be awful I need something better
than this hand gun whatever oops okay we
need to find the box and the pack of
punch machine and there are so many
Easter eggs I'm probably just walking
right past oh yeah for sure
you can't stop to look at the easter
eggs right now okay I can't do anything
apparently oh yeah you know I try to
press this button for the names but I
think it's I didn't yeah it's arm when I
did they would sit up on me I was like
[Music]
wow the zombies their lag switching yeah
you did this guy's too good he needs to
like ya know it's losses and you should
also use your your potion on the right
okay to give you some melee protection
and then I don't know if you'll need it
this round cuz we got our powerup guy
right here I can follow him but it's so
cheap I don't think we've unlocked that
one yet but that one is is it like just
liquefies all the zombies nearby so cool
crime with an F in the chat thank you
not yet yeah is top tier the monkey
sacrificed his life for us that is how
much of a homey
Oh see we got that protection we have
this no can I put it away with no you
can't you have to use it now you've got
mr. perfect hey would you die please
oh yeah we're at level 15 now oh no
really my friends I can help this zombie
is well done zombie cooked over a high
heat oh boy
oh yeah new gun ASAP as usual thanks
Nikita was very kind whoa modern warfare
just released gameplay oh no way I'm
excited for that are you I am i I am a
fan of modern warfare
me too oh man this little shack always
has to get ease
actually I think we're close to it
changes every round that's fun inch
because I didn't notice there's a power
up in that Shack like every time
interesting ok I grabbed it and now I'm
ready to go start off the level right
I'm still like not against getting rid
of this weapon we gotta find the box
yeah this is really good I think it's in
the bunker yeah we have to go back
underground
let's team up yeah everybody thanks back
oh yes you are getting tanky now they
take a few maybe use your left potion so
you can move faster and they're running
from the other things oh no all the dog
oh there we go we're getting help from
crime go to the generator you've been to
before and hit the red but
aha wait what does that do is that what
gives us the box back am i like turn on
the generators cuz there's a lot of
things that around here that still
require power oh right right right
I think and some of the stuff you need
like all your teammates yes there was
something that yet that's straight up
said you need to be where's the bunker
entrance don't know why I mean we do
actually
maybe one behind each other questions on
bees hopping over my fence get out of my
lawn okay
perfect time for Nick here we go okay we
just have to search for this box really
quick it's not down there I could get
out I'm getting smoked out over here and
now it's stanky down here oh okay now
you be a good area to circle but you
have to do that alone okay I'm going in
circles so where's the box yeah just now
it's time to stay down here with the
squad I think someone threw a monkey
bomb I get your needs and my
flamethrower and also maybe a left
potion oh yeah unforgiving with that gun
Oh box is in the beds area look for the
signs Oh oh yeah I forgot there are
always signs like granada's yes that's
right you know what the box just
launched did you see oh I saw it I saw
it oh go away someone probably yeah not
the mannequin head again dang it dang it
oh and there's dog oh boy oh no it's a
it's okay I think you're gonna get
damaged bones too brave of a old school
Cod strat right there hey where they go
maybe they need to come all out there's
one thank you oh here we go
oh my lord teammate so far they are oh
no no we're running that guy's frantic I
don't like the bunker where's the box oh
go away right we're shopping here yeah
yes yes all right
don't die what is it Oh oh my lord you
need to get close to the teammates
there's the way out go that way
don't die
swear you die with this gun screams
we're good we got all the squad here
it's okay it's okay so all the teams
here then pick you up
I need the classic line revive me I have
a ray gun I know right I have a ray gun
these guys again oh no we have cooler
guys but this guy is powerup you also
have your power up if you want to
conserve some ammo which one is l1 r1
together oh you have a like a smidge of
meter left sorry I don't want to pick it
up someone pick it up
I can't ping do you imagine a peg Jim
what apex nice okay you got it whatever
you deserve it
you almost have your power-ups like kill
one more zombie I know there's people
behind you yes okay I'm out of here I
hate this bunker so much I feel like you
have to do something down oh those
little things shocking me yeah these are
friends friends friendlies
we're invincible to fire Oh
you know these things are so gross I'm
back whew that was intense but we're on
level 18 jumpy no I really want mine you
have a gun I'm freaked out all the power
oh that's the other gun yeah we need to
get rid of that bad boy where's the box
yeah this guy was cool at first he's too
slow and clunky Oh new area wow I was
just trying to appreciate the map I
haven't seen yet now we have two people
down this is no bueno
oh man home way has 14,000 you gotta go
you might die we have three people down
this might be the end of the road you
can see them generator red screen
survive in the generator area go up in
each Gasthaus pull the valve go back to
the beds area and pack a punch oh crime
knows everything jump in the game with
us would you man oh that's so cool and I
was so close to it not cool and it's
alright I probably wouldn't have known
what to do with it
this guy I know yeah bsut Raider sir oh
man Gigi's if he pulls this off he is a
zombie God yeah you can just come work
here
he's rounding them up not shooting yet
he's about to I can tell his alts is
almost done so he's probably just trying
to run around he's gonna build up his
meter just a tad we had four of these
guys on a team we just never end
he almost has the second he has his all
he's gonna obliterate everyone which I
can't wait actually be able to clutch
this out once you get that you they're
so slimy what is this I wish that were
me playing okay he has it he has it it's
time to go him I thought it was the
other guy with the one that does the
bull ground pounds spectres Spectre
rising yeah oh no it's over yeah can I
please y'all know what to do yeah you
know do so many apps in the chat first
those if you flood my feed with this
that was good though that was that was a
great round that was really fun that guy
definitely carried us but he knew it you
know the Raygun that was exciting time
it was fun that mark to Regan that's
like kind of like semi-auto it's fun
I've never done haven't played with that
one yet all right so hey maybe we should
there was like a horde mode and in
blackouts who you want to give that a
girl I mean we should check that out
we got about 15 minutes left of the
stream thanks for tuning in and watching
it so far
might not be the best oh snap mystical
Nisha's bagless uh I love seeing our
returning returning theses yeah
usernames or however we should describe
those thanks for joining us all right
let's check out the black outlet very
much no not really actually same like I
got my feet wet with it and I just kind
of moved on like I uh I don't know I I'm
not good that was one thing that really
turned me off I'm just not good at B R
in general so that's just me yeah I
think it's cool though that they are
giving people like a ton of different
Cod options you know it's like a regular
mode Old Faithful campaign in Old
Faithful zombies hmm oh and also
blackout if we take everything we didn't
have a campaign this time but like it
was it had everything else it was kind
of like I don't know if the community
doesn't even miss the campaign that's
why I was saying I feel like a lot more
people than just myself hop on to these
games and don't even play campaign there
looks like jump right in a multiplayer
yeah alright it's so a horde blackout
mode so apparently from what they said
here there's like all these zombies and
different new and different types of
zombies mm-hmm that spawn throughout the
map so sweet they had regular zombies
and blackout if you go to a specific
area now it sounds like they varied up
what kind of zombies will show up that's
cool how do you get operation apocalypse
Z so I would say just go to your market
place it's a there's a pass right
there's like a season pass you can get
or you could just buy the operation and
outright yeah it should be in the PSN
store or the within your menus of Call
of Duty it's there too it's like it's
advertised so if you click on it it will
link you to the store you can download
it there
crime is on Xbox you can't join us
we need you man or we play on xbox next
time
so this should be interesting like I
said I really do but I don't know I
think it's cool that it's like Federale
but then it's also like oh hey there
were zombies everywhere Oh what the heck
you're a monkey oh not suit but yeah
those feet look funny I thought they
were funny shoes and then I was like
wait you're the monkey character I
forgot all other players yeah sure no
problem
yeah that fresh air those friendly
people oh look it looks like you have a
team okay cool about that although I
don't think I landed near anybody okay
I'm also horrible at looting so you know
it's fine no no this is family here in
the chat there you go she is story of my
life running around forever picking up
everything except for the attachments oh
my goodness teammates there bandages
also don't know where I'm going Lulu
Crime says you got this I think you can
respond in this oh that's the fact then
we got a fighting chance here man the
team just there all the way over there I
know I'm like I'm comment save some guns
for us have you been to Alcatraz before
no I realize yeah I was like is that a
thing yeah it's a it's a real prison
know there I mean I know it's like a
prison stuff I didn't think it was like
oh anyone can just film it yeah good
nice but it is a tourist location now
used to be a prison but it's you know I
would say two miles from us here in the
San Francisco office oh I did
like it was that close it's fun you
should try it out it's like you get a
little audio tour if you want and it's
it's spooky but like there's a date or
that's just fine it's also very cool and
fascinating and it's it's this scale
this this map is modeled really well
after it no oh the monkey Oh take the
calories oh yeah say that for in cod4
when you got down and you had last and
[Laughter]
yeah I was like go to safety
alright I still have to figure out how
the heck oh l one till you see his band
okay hold it down nice I'm sorry guys I
should have played a couple of rounds
with this book where I decided no way
thanks for exciting this way who does
this have an easter egg I'm not sure I
wouldn't say I wouldn't guess so let
this oh you were oh oh I'm dead okay
here we go
redeploying mmm I don't think
that's what you want to do in zombies
right there right when you're like Oh
run into the wall yeah yeah you do that
message whoa is this you being revived
what is this thing so you're being
redeployed I don't know is it a hot zone
okay sweet you're back oh yeah there was
one other person be careful down that
guy with the Mohawk oh man all got him
you got it no you're fine look at all
this loot don't tell your friends are
gonna steal it away oh my gosh sorry
guys that are not elute in this game
you're fine there you go how do i okay
here we go
noise your backpack well no it can't be
hey yo you're picking it all up yeah
very good I finally figured it out I'm
like pressing all the apex buttons I'm
like crime says nice that to peace you
got earlier knock those guys down yeah
with my pistol yep that's kind of cool
that they drop you with a weapon though
cuz like an apex like oh you're getting
a respawned have fun running around with
your fully looted this is funny you can
just keep dropping in it doesn't make
for such a quick game yeah I'm kind of
curious as to like how that works out in
the end yeah how does it end I mean
maybe you have wives team line there you
go
[Music]
it's okay I'm a monkey
[Laughter]
ribs cheese hey still not out I know I'm
like trying to look around my screen
here and see like do we have that looks
like a Louie Vuitton skin on that show
we are high-fashion oh hey did you get
him put away I'm saying I wonder if our
ever our like perception just wasn't as
accurate as what he saw I was like none
of those bullets first like I thought
you were playing you worried we were
watching that
here we go top right of the screen the
circle arrow is how many respawns you
have left yes thank you needed that what
is this raising in crime thank you
r14 razor wire okay okay kind of dark oh
that's so rude executed you I am like
Joe spoil by apex because I was like
wait is that a prison it's kind of dark
you can't tell yeah like anything
everything everything's bright I'm
trying I can't oh yeah you can't turn it
as much there you go okay I need like
some shields and a helmet
yeah okay I'm good most of the team sold
what's this okay oh yeah finally
teammate oh that guy is lime green soup
thing I definitely think he killed me
more than once
oh sorry hey you still got some kills on
me I literally use every life on our
team we are out of deployments no
pressure
are they there like hugging the ring
okay that's a way to play battle royale
that is a technique just hug in the ring
but that was a friendly okay good good
what are they doing they're like hanging
out ok Lauraine crime last one that's
what he says it's true I used to use
them all yeah
well we know now - that's how thanks to
crime okay
oh it's kind of quiet I know what I
agree frustration oh wait you're a
monkey
okay good you got something right now
you get 75 bullets sweet but no reserves
this is it though last life look at now
there's an now people are really sorry
inside there was like 26 people left now
there's only you got your whole squad
we're not here okay I was like oh maybe
I'm not drop anything oh you got a
kizomba kill oh maybe you can new
secondary there rib okay you know what
looting is weird but I think I got the
hang of it now yeah you've made some
progress just in one game
very nice cuz like in Apex you can like
open the box and just like mesh yeah and
everything everything you have to
actually like move so you have to be
calculated can be a scrub just mash
buttons
alright well around one more oh yeah
guys we need an F in the chat yeah flood
the chance okay we did we also free like
a long time
oh that hole dropping in system where
you keep reading that wasn't it's cool
it's not just all over and done when
you're down look yeah they look
selectable noise oh that's the guy I
play I like recon cos get back oh here's
the new here I'll be using you oh oh
raided our Pathfinder Bastion oh there
is thank you crime for that I
need a picture of all three robots next
to each other in Pathfinder and then cat
what's-his-name against Reaper yeah
Reaper
this guy's cool-looking looks like a
Iron Man with a different helmet alright
I got this
you do you got a feel for it I do I've
leveled up yeah hopefully you have a
more helpful squad this time - hey bait
helped in terms of letting me use all
the respawn
hey that map looks familiar did you see
that part of the map it looked like the
asylum map from call of duty zombies
which they are they combine multiple
maps to make a mess that's really fun
yeah when Black Ops was like I'm sorry
when black out was first announced it
was so cool to see previous black ops
maps and you got this Oh rocket oh just
one rocket you totally got this how many
shots I can't tell these guys invincible
the heck you landed like every side
I'm confusion oh I'm this freaking
smartest person in the world I dunno I
was you were landing every shot it was
great practice but we were both
bamboozled just now that guy was
probably like why is this person
shooting me so seriously I know that I
hurt blue Paul gave us an F and I think
it was better when I was in practice man
oh God what sort of American History X
that down but not out okay that's fine
what that was that was a rough that was
rude yeah dang it in general though
getting finished in games for me it's
like oh I think I'm starting to notice
something isn't there a champ that wait
what happened we're dead dead already
uh-oh was that a different game but on
that note at least we got my amazing
accuracy in practice mode on stream
definitely that was a that was a
highlight for sure
anywho you guys yeah that's gonna wrap
it up for the stream today but that was
fun that was that was there was so much
added to this DLC drop zombies of course
was fun but even the rest yeah and you
know we didn't even really shop any of
the new multiplayer stuff we showed off
a handful of blackout things but
definitely check it out
operation apocalypse Z new content for
blob sport so yeah I had a lot of fun so
I would definitely recommend it if you
guys want to check it out and thank you
Ritchie for joining thanks for having me
on
everyone make sure you come back
tomorrow for community Fridays with John
Luke and Ben
always great time and if I don't see you
guys in chat next time then I'll see you
next week have a great weekend and peace
out bye guys